>> Rishi Chandra: Again, so all of a sudden
now we can create enhanced experiences around
Android applications as well. And what's compelling
here is not only can users now have consistent
application across multiple devices but you
as a developer can now have additional devices
take your application.
And now we can also enable you to create entirely
new experiences directly on Google TV. Something
optimized specifically for the living room.
And we are giving you two application frameworks,
Web apps and Android apps.
Now, we have some work to do. So the Android
Market and the Google TV specific SDK will
be coming shortly after product availability,
but to give you a sense of where the platform
is going, we want to give you a few developer
demos. And to do that I would like to introduce
Ambarish Kenghe, lead developer PM for Google
TV.
>>Ambarish Kenghe: Thanks, Rishi. Today I
would like to talk about how you as developers
can get involved with the Google TV platform
and showcase a few example applications and
Web sites.
First of all, you can optimize for the TV
screen. Most Web sites, as you would expect,
in many applications would run on Google TV
as they are. Today, we would also publish
very simple guidelines on how to quickly enhance
your Web site for a great TV experience.
But optimizing Web sites is just the beginning.
We want to empower the developer community
to create integrated experiences across Web
and TV content and to enable that, we will
provide you with a set of Web and Android
APIs which will allow you to navigate TV content.
For example, you can directly search to a
TV channel that you like, or you can record
a TV show, all directly from your Web sites
and applications.